salut c'est jimmy et je suis extrêmement
ravi de vous retrouver pour confiner
d'ici et d'ailleurs si ce nouveau rendez
vous que vous offre la première pour
partir à la découverte de ses ex patrons
comme on les appelle c'est guadeloupéens
martiniquais guyanais qui ont décidé de
vivre loin de leur pays d'origine
alors aujourd'hui on va essayer de
savoir quelles sont les raisons qui les
ont motivés à partir comment ils vivent
leur nouvelle vie dans leur pays
d'adoption
et en cette période si particulière de
confinement comment ça se passe pour eux
aujourd'hui je vous emmène très très
loin en lettonie en part à la rencontre
de jean christophe riz hernie il est
commandant de bord bonjour jean
christophe
alors quoi tu es à riga en lettonie
c'est ça les gay tony
ça fait partie des trois pays baltes
donc si on peu loin de la martinique
c'est à l'extrême l'extrême et le
alors qu'est ce qui t'a amené aussi loin
de la martinique ah ben occasions
professionnelles opportunités
professionnelles des volets dans mon
métier qu'est ce qu'il a dit donc voilà
la compagnie nationale m'a donné la
chance voilà d'évoluer chez moi qui ai
commandant de bord qui était donc au
contact de beaucoup de passagers de
touristes de personnes potentiellement
contaminées comment tu l'as vécu toi tu
as fait on fait vraiment tout le décor
entendu parler du coup on a un virus
effectivement bailly
le planning est un autre changer donc on
voit des gens masqués et ses collègues
un peu inquiet au pape
on contacte avec des gens qui étaient
peut-être grippé vous pouvez peut-être
déjà atteint du coronavirus beaucoup
d'inquiétude
et puis finalement on va tout s'est
accéléré parce que le l'état a mis en
place des restrictions et effectivement
on arrive très vite les vols pour pour
éviter les contacts avec sa femme
passagers qui pourraient qui pouvait
être atteint 2 je sais qu'en fonction
des pays une gestion différente qui est
fait
on ne vient pas forcément en lettonie la
crise comme on la gère en france comment
est-ce que c'est chez vous en france et
confinement pour le moment en lettonie
c'est comment donc la compagne de vos
culs et les frontières sont fermées
par contre effectivement nous on peut
sortir on a la liberté de sortir donc on
va aller faire ses courses promener les
chiens du sport on va au parc etc
par contre on doit voilà de temps en
temps des abus policiers passent dans
les rues avec la mégafaune qui demandent
de respecter la distance de 2 mètres
entre chaque personne dans les magasins
aussi tout votre soeur elle est fait
pour des marques et les distances entre
les personnes dans le magasin c'est pas
mal c'est pas mal fait et le
gouvernement aussi à tous et toutes les
entreprises qui pouvaient un
fonctionnement télétravail est donc donc
vraiment ils ont réagi très très vite et
bien chez nous on accueille 500 4 pour
une population à peu près de deux
millions d'habitants
on va parler des choses positives
maintenant qu'est ce que tu aimes en
lettonie est ce qu'il ya des choses
particulières si on était amené à venir
en vacances en lettonie après le
confinement bien évidemment après le
coït 19
qu'est ce que tu nous conseillerais de
venir voir absolument alors c'est très
rapide effectivement étayer ce qui est
bien c'est le fallait 3 p justement
renton lettonie lituanie parce qu'elle
est capital sont petites mais elles sont
[Musique]
fondées
on parle de d'anciennes villes et de
nouvelles villes je suis potel la
nouvelle bible et ancien hilali est
réparé
il a beaucoup guy lange et culture
orthodoxe des cathos et un peu plus
encore et donc les connes belle église
plein de beaux monuments aussi et faire
le tour la lettonie s'est très
rapidement le tour la capitaine ce
patron de fermer trois par exemple en
lituanie en plein milieu de la capitale
qui ont atteint au château des baux être
fort et cccs que des spécialités
culinaires ans par exemple en lettonie
la barre martini pas que toutes ces
périodes qui sont qui sont marquées par
des choses qu'on mange plus
spécifiquement on a dénombré on a not
not to lose
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il y as qu'il ya
un autre match et essayer des choses
c'est beaucoup de blanc comme comme fin
d'études du boeuf à dans une espèce de
rage ou qu'ils font mais local nec
pourquoi vous que ce qu'on achète et vit
son approche de la terre nous c'est
souvent des volontaires beaucoup de
fromages aussi parce qu'ils aiment bien
peu gratiné leur leurs blagues wallabies
n'ont le pays et est une référence
je fais beaucoup de plats que je fais
goûter à des collègues et ouais c'est
pour ça que l'on a déjà pu visiter nos
tripes mais merci d'être l'ambassadeur
de la martinique aussi loin en lettonie
est un plaisir d'échanger quelques mots
avec toi jean christophe prudence bien
évidemment et puis on espère te revoir
très bientôt sur un vol qui l'emmènera
cette fois en vacances en martinique et
on se retrouvera sur la plage pour
manger d accra et compagnie voilà
j'espère que cet échange vous aura donné
envie qui sait de découvrir la lettonie
mais après le confinement on se retrouve
très vite sur martinique la première
pour une nouvelle destination à très
bientôt
[Musique]